Florida's largest power company is using
a military-type operation and more than
19,000 workers to restore electricity
drone video shows how armored tore
through the fishing village of Goodland
that's in Southwest Florida many homes
are damaged Jonathan Vigliotti is in
Bonita Springs that's between Fort Myers
and Naples where people are starting to
go home Jonathan good morning good
morning many people returning back to
scenes like this homes that look like
Islands Rana Street right now where the
water is actually starting to recede and
we're seeing people weighed their way
back to their homes we've also seen
people driving through this water but
yesterday the water was so deep up to my
waist that we watched as people lined up
here on the streets with kayaks and
canoes to paddle their way back home
this Bonita Springs neighborhood of
mostly wood frame and cinderblock homes
has been inundated the water is creeping
up to the mailboxes if you look here you
can see the water line coming up to the
door we're actually in the back of a
truck from a homeowner down here who had
to evacuate when this storm hit many
people were in their homes at the time
in the middle of the night having to
leave in waist-deep water Bonita Springs
is along the Imperial River which had
swelled before Erma blew through Kelly
McClinton and her boyfriend Daniel had
to put on waders to return home this is
the second flood in like two weeks and
so it stopped we just got barely out to
clean it up before and now we're under
again Michael Holly says with a half
foot of water in his house he's worried
about a lengthy recovery
I don't know how lines gonna take don't
know how long I'll be able to move back
in and actually live a normal life again
America's tomato capital Immokalee was
one of the hardest hit areas we saw
multiple homes with roofs ripped off
Jesse never on tea and his family wrote
out the storms is the stronger than
you've been yeah I've been through a
couple um this is one that really hit us
getting in you know what next time they
say leave back away I'm going just down
the road Deborah Estrada said some
people in this migrant farming commune
were too afraid to evacuate or seek help
a lot of people were scared to go to
shelters because of the cops were there
asking for IDs a lot of these people
don't have identification and Deborah
Shradha says she worries about her
community not getting the help it needs
Governor Rick Scott was actually
inimical yesterday visiting a shelter
where he told people no one would be
forgotten regardless of their
immigration status Charlie
Jonathan thanked